Jacob is with us in Los Angeles welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show Jacob hey Dave
how were you better than I deserve man
what's up I have a question about a
leased car and what I should do okay
at the end of this month I'll be making
the last payment and I'm looking at some
of the options when I first got the car
I was thinking about just buying it and
so I didn't get very many miles a year
needless to say I'm grossly grossly over
on miles right now about 18,000 20 25
cents a mile you know that's gonna be
four or five thousand dollars out of
pocket we were thinking about buying it
so we have about twenty six thousand
dollars in cash right now the car
contract says the buyout price is about
$24,000 dr. tax and he is about 25 the
Kelley Blue Book for private sale is
somewhere between 19 and 20 so I feel
like I'm gonna be overpaying for our car
now I really like the car my wife loves
the car too but uh I don't know if I
necessarily want to I feel like I'm
gonna be making a bad decision if I do
buy the car I'm thinking about selling
it but I haven't got very many bites on
like auto trader and some of these
marketplaces so I don't know I feel like
either way I'm going to be taking a loss
yeah well I mean the value plus $4,500
is your is your is your threshold right
$4,500 is your milage penalty and so if
the value is 19 then 24 is a deal buy
500 bucks if the value is 20 then you're
in the hole 500 bucks you're not getting
a deal on this car at 24 you're not
overpaying $5,000 for it though I mean
you might be paying over paying $500 for
it okay you're overpaying for it but
you're going to give them $4,500 if you
turn it in correct so that's on the
table right so I guess what I would do
is contact the dealership and who holds
the lease its financial yeah contact
them and see if there's sometimes on
these things they're not always but
sometimes you can make them an offer at
you know Bluebook and they'll take that
because they're gonna take the car and
do what with it sell it okay
yeah they're gonna run down the auction
line and it's not going to bring
nineteen at the auction line and so
let's say it brings you know its
wholesale at that point trade-in value
is what it's going to bring if they
wholesale it and they run their leased
cars down the auction lines what they do
with them usually so you know if they're
going to do that then they're going to
get a in the equivalent of a trade-in
value for this which might be 17 and 17
plus your forty five hundred is less
than the twenty four thousand they're
trying to get out of you so if you kind
of make that case to them look up
trade-in value and call them and go okay
you know I would be willing to pay you
more than trade-in value because that's
all you're gonna get for it when I turn
it into you cuz I got to give you $4,500
anyway matter of fact I'll probably give
you forty five hundred on top of
trade-in value which is less than twenty
four what would you take for it and see
if you can negotiate the price to that
and then if you buy that car are you
going to keep that car and drive it yeah
okay all right then you've got the cash
to do it and that's what I would do
I'm trying to get the price down under
twenty four okay yeah I called them and
didn't look like they wanted to play
ball and then I called the dealership to
see if they would you know buy and sell
for me less to try to keep a customer
kind of thing and it doesn't seem like
any of them really want to do anything
but I have until the end of the month I
guess or end of next month to figure
well you've already done what I told you
to do then okay you're ahead of me yeah
yeah I mean just take another run or two
at it but here's the thing if you turn
the car in and you bought a car
identical to it you're going to pay
twenty thousand dollars for that car
yeah and you will have given them four
thousand five hundred dollars that's
twenty four five so if you like this car
I'd pay them twenty four for it worst
case yeah and keep it and you got that
cause you got the cash to do that I
don't want to I don't want them to write
it down one thing every every dime they
write it down under twenty four thousand
makes this much more palatable if
they're if the buyout on the thing was
27 I hand them the keys if they were
hardcore
because that's a $3,000 swing then but
you're right at a break even which means
they calculate this lease perfectly
that's what it means
ouch so they don't usually do that by
the way they're they're pretty good at
it they don't usually lose money but
this one there yeah so anyway just keep
messing with them see if you can get
them to cut it down you know if you'll
knock it off thousand dollars I'll take
it somebody help me here I'm just trying
to save you the trouble taking the car
and running it you know of course for
them it's just a job for you at your car
so who knows good luck with that but I
that that's a worst case in your
situation I'm buying the car for 20 for
worst case I hate it but I would do that
hey thanks for the call open phones at
Triple Eight 8 to 5 5 2 to 5 see the car
fleece we call it a fleece because
you're being fleeced is the most
expensive way to operate an automobile
every possible way that general motors
on that deal is going to lose money they
have covered if the mileage goes up they
make you eat it
if there's wear and tear on the car
that's excessive they make you eat it
if you want to buy the car you're gonna
pay freakin retail for this car more
than retail for this car and it's as is
conditioned and that's if they you know
locked in on the contract it's closed in
lease you pay the lease payments up to
the last payment and then you buy the
car or you write a check and cover the
mileage hole that you're in when you put
all of those factors in there and you
figure what the MSRP on the car is you
can calculate out and figure out that
their rate of return on the money they
have used while they let you rent their
car their rate of return on average on a
car fleece is about 14.2% it's like
financing a car at 14% this is what's
known as freaking stupid okay not that
guy but just everybody out there just
for those of you you know think
releasing your cord leasing a car stupid
it's the most expensive way to operate
an automobile and that guy's numbers
were classic case study of it right
there
again I'm not picking on him I'm not
yelling at him I'm yelling at those of
you that still think this is smart
because it's not smart you're renting a
car and any possibility of any loss by
the manufacturer that's carrying the car
fleece paper has been covered they got
it dialed in they did ten thousand just
like you last year twenty five thousand
just like you last year and they've got
this dialed in they know what this
stinking car is going to be worth they
know how much it's going to go down in
value you are covering all the loss of
value in your fleece payments that's how
this works they're not in this business
to lose money they're not do anything
illegal they're not scamming you it's
just the most expensive way to operate a
car the least expensive way to operate a
car is write a check and buy it and if
you don't have a net worth of at least a
million dollars don't be buying a new
car let someone else take the
butt-kicking on the depreciation when
you drive a car off the car lot that's
sound when you go over the curb blump
blump was five thousand bucks
boom boom that's what this sounds like
that's what five thousand dollars sounds
like boom boom when your tires go over
the curb if you don't believe me turn
around the block later and take it back
over there and see if they'll take it
back that's where you'll find out what
you just lost a new car loses 60 to 70%
of its value in the next four years
that's turning $30,000 into $10,000 on a
regular basis and scratching your head
and wondering why you're broke if I
tried to sell you a mutual fund that you
put thirty thousand dollars in the
turned into ten thousand every three
years and that was its track record over
the last thirty years you would call me
the biggest scam artist snake oil
salesman on the planet and yet you line
up to buy these dadgum brand new cars
and scratch your head and wonder why
your kids college fund it and fund it